[Music]
you know I
um I think I should call the
bank you know what you're probably right
but there goes my job and there goes all
your
data my kids pictures are on this
computer
[Music]
okay that is what I am talking about
come
on let
me love you people I love
you hello hello you still
there
uh
oh you're a blessing Mr Clay this place
was crab grass and weeds and you brought
it back to life
Mrs Parker and I were friends she was
like family she was the only person who
ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this yesterday she shot herself this is
private property do you know what they
do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm count to three one 2
three there I did it for
you no you can't take it you I'm going
to burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I pretend
the hide when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have WS for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
bro don't
move
down this is much bigger than that a
little fishing
scam the money's going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem get damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming here straight
through the back entrance I fig i' give
the firefighters a break somebody detain
this
guy
die we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as who
know
[Music]